is there anything more exciting than
seeing characters from your favorite TV
series come to life we don't think so
and these 10 Ben 10 ultra fans
definitely agree so if you've ever
wondered what SpiderMonkey would look
like in real life make sure to stick
around until the end of the video don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this and give this
video a big thumbs up now join us as we
take a look at 10 Ben 10 aliens in real
life Wildmutt there are not many things
in the world cuter than dogs these furry
creatures really have it all a swinging
tail tons of energy and a human-like
sense of companionship that makes them
the perfect pet well we would be tempted
to call Wildmutt a dog he's actually
missing a few too many attributes to be
really considered one for example did
you know that this little guy does not
have any eyes since he does not have
ordinary vision he is forced to rely on
other ways of orienting himself one way
that he gets around is using a sort of
thermo map a dull 3d map based on where
his senses originate pretty cool right
even more crazy as wildmutt's sense of
smell given that he has no visible nose
you might be a little confused as to how
he has the ability to smell at all well
it turns out that Wildmutt actually has
three gill-like appendages on his head
that act as his sensory receptors using
these gills
Wildmutt is able to track down almost
anything simply based on its scent one
artist xx drummer xx made an extremely
lifelike version of wild mutt and boy
did he do an absolutely incredible job
you can tell that the artist behind it
is a true Benton fan because he took the
time and care to include wild mutts
invaluable 3 gills talk about attention
to detail for arms if you don't mind
please take a second to look down at
your arms and consider how valuable they
are to your everyday life seriously
think about all the times you've used
them to grab boxes of cereal tire shoe
or even make a nice French omelet now
think about how off-the-wall awesome it
would be to have two more of them well
welcome to the life of one of our
favorite Ben 10 characters for arms
beyond his extra grabbers this humanoid
alien is just all-around impressive he's
got two pairs of eyes bright red skin
and he's thought to be about 12 feet
tall wouldn't it be amazing to be 12
feet tall you'd be able to reach every
last fig on the old fig tree and you
could scratch almost any ceiling you
wanted but
his enormous girth this big dude is much
slower than many of his opponents worry
not though because he's got some pretty
top-of-the-line powers to make up for
his speed one of fourarms awesome
abilities is called the sonic clap which
would also be a great nickname for a
guitar the artist Simon FX who rendered
forearms in real life really captured
his ferocity and all of his signature
attributes he's got four eyes forearms
and even the black strip running down
his face the details in this piece are
downright stunning just take a look at
those muscles diamond Ted diamonds have
a long history that dates as far back as
3,000 years ago in India since they were
first discovered these rare jewels have
been sought-after for their beauty and
insane durability did you know the word
diamond comes from an ancient Greek word
meaning unalterable well don't say that
to Diamond Head because he loves
changing the shape of his crystalline
body that's right
this green silicon-based life-form has
the incredible ability to change his
shape at any moment Diamond had uses his
power in a few different ways first of
all he uses this ability to quickly
create awesome fighting gear for example
blades and bludgeons he also turns
crystals into shield walls and ramps
that assist him in any battle he may
encounter oh and did we mention that he
can also create and shoot projectile
crystals at a moment's notice well yeah
he can not only kid die Minh had create
all this from scratch but his
prison-like body is actually able to
diffuse his enemies lasers and other
similar weapons pretty epic this tough
guy isn't without his weaknesses though
he can chip and crack pretty easily with
a fighter this intense it definitely
isn't easy to find a real-life
doppelganger to do him justice but we
think we found a pretty good one
equipped with refracting diamond skin
and the signature spike on his head
this diamonds head is as close to real
as can be Ghostfreak is there anything
more downright spooky than a real live
ghost well
Ghostfreak certainly gets close this
phantom like alien is as scary as can be
with a gaseous appearance and some big
old claw hands it must be hard to do
delicate things with those big old claw
hands imagine trying to shell navy beans
so a small button onto your favorite
blouse or grab just a pinch of salt with
those long fingers as difficult as these
hands might be Ghostfreak manages to get
along just fine by using his other
powers being nearly as light as air this
ghostly guy has the amazing ability to
fly so
when he's not flying you might find him
or not find him using his power of
invisibility as you learn more and more
about this character you can't help but
realize just how special he is unlike
anyone we've ever met Ghostfreak skin is
actually removable underneath his skin
he's got some pretty intense tentacles
as you can tell this is one scary dude
we thought it would be impossible to
find someone that could fully capture
all of the amazingness that his
Ghostfreak
then we found lil ik's lil --ax is an
incredible cosplayer that created an
even more incredible Ghostfreak costume
she's got long spidery claws wispy skin
and cloak and some spooky striped tights
she must have taken a long long time to
put this little gem together
Heatblast have you ever heard the
expression if you can't stand the heat
then you better get out of this kitchen
well it might be better to say if you
can't stand the heat you better not mess
with heatblast yes this next character
is the hottest alien on the list mainly
because he's actually made of magma that
is a spicy meatball and a spicy dish
overall outside of the liquid magma that
runs bright yellow throughout his body
heat blast is covered with red rocks
unsurprisingly this epic character has
the ability to control fire can you say
the perfect piece of toast beyond his
trademark pyrokinesis heat blast has a
few powerful tricks up his sleeve given
that he's made a fire
he is also totally immune to fire this
power combined with his ability to fly
would definitely make heat blast the
best professional firefighter around no
matter how powerful he might be
everybody has their weaknesses although
you might not expect it he blasts is
actually immune to ice and to the cold
water on the other hand is his only
weakness when heat blast is surrounded
by an overwhelming amount of water he
can temporarily lose his heat you know
who never loses his heat this little boy
that dressed up his heat blast never
loses his heat and what's more he's come
up with a complete costume this young
man has heat blast scorching mask his
lava filled body and even the red rocks
this kid is bringing some serious warmth
accelerate one of the coolest aliens
from the television series Ben 10 has
got to be the one and only accelerate
not only is he the coolest but he's also
one of the fastest aliens around we have
to imagine that his speed was the
inspiration for his very clever name
this blue dude can react and think at
superhuman speeds simultaneously
considering thousands of different
options at once excel
it can also move extremely fast in fact
he's been known to travel at speeds up
to 500 miles per hour which is faster
than almost any car he moves with such
incredible velocity that he is also able
to run across water which is an
invaluable ability that he uses to catch
enemies of all types one of the first
things you might notice about accelerate
is his physical appearance at first
glance this cool dude resembles a sort
of semi armored Velociraptor unlike
normal velociraptors however he's got
black wheels on his feet that allow him
to reach insane speeds being the
responsible alien that he is accelerate
always wears his trusty helmet better
safe than sorry we've got two different
real-life versions of accelerate to show
you today this first one was obviously
made by and for someone a bit younger as
the costume is quite ill-fitting the
second version however is absolutely
spot-on this costume made by cosplayer
health III has got it all the bright
blue skin the tail and even accelerate
signature wheels grey matter
one of the lessons we learn over and
over again is not to judge a book by its
cover
well you had better get ready to learn
it all over again because our next alien
is not quite what he seems on first
sight it seems like grey matter would be
the weakest alien of them all let's face
it he's actually pretty small and he
also looks like a frog
the only frog we've ever been afraid of
was the old mascot for the WB but if you
look a bit closer you'll see that this
little guy actually has some pretty
intimidating features most importantly
he's got some extremely sharp teeth that
can bite through almost anything beyond
that gray matter is also amphibious
which means he can use his gills to
breathe underwater you bet that comes in
handy looks aside grey matter has a lot
going on underneath the hood did we
mention that he's basically a genius
well he is and because of that he often
plays the role of problem solver in
Benton that's right what he may lack in
brute force gray matter definitely makes
up for it with his cunning intellect and
strategic mind we're so excited to find
this live-action version of grey matter
the first thing you may notice about
this picture is how well it represents
the Frog like alien size based on this
depiction
gray matter is hardly any bigger than an
everyday Styrofoam cup with an alien
that small he's lucky to be so smart Ben
Tennyson although we are mainly focused
on aliens today it would be silly not to
talk a little bit about the star of the
show Ben Tennyson Ben was just an
ordinary 10 year old boy until he found
a piece of technology that would chain
his life forever this piece of
technology was of course the Omnitrix
the Omnitrix is a watch like device that
gives Ben the ability to turn into ten
different aliens pretty incredible
technology for such a young man right
Ben's age is actually an important part
of his personality like any 10 year old
Ben absolutely loves to have fun and
totally hates any sort of cleaning like
many kids his age he often floats
through the world in a clumsy or
reckless manner but he mostly uses the
Omnitrix to fight evil don't be
surprised if you catch him using it for
personal reasons - in all fairness who
could blame him if we had a watch like
that we'd be turning into aliens like it
was nobody's business one downside of
the Omnitrix however is that once Ben
assumes a new alien form he also assumes
that aliens weakness but hey nothing's
perfect
one thing that's near perfect though is
this cosplayers representation of Ben's
outfit seriously this cosplayer named
imep load totally nailed it
he's got the watch the jacket and even
the badge now let's see if he can turn
into some awesome aliens Swamp fire
what's partially red totally awesome and
has the ability to control plants the
Sun is all of those things kind of but
in this case we're talking about one of
our favorite aliens from the Ben 10
series swamp fire yes this humanoid
plant like alien has some pretty
incredible skills for example did you
know that he's actually able to control
plant matter this ability called chloro
Kinesis takes many different forms
throughout the series in one episode we
might find Swamp fire telepathically
communicating with plants using his mind
to make them grow and creating organic
matter seemingly out of nowhere in
another episode you might find him
projecting seeds and gases at any one of
his opponents if we had these incredible
skills we definitely take up gardening
just think of all the rich meaty
Tomatoes he could grow beyond chloro
Kinesis swamp fire has the power to
ignite methane in his palms which
creates his very own flamethrower he's
also able to use this methane as a form
of propulsion taking temporary flight at
a moment's notice with all these amazing
abilities you might be wondering what
swamp fires weaknesses
well like almost all plant matter this
alien is susceptible to being frozen an
alien this awesome definitely needs a
totally rockin doppelganger and we found
just the match check out this real-life
version of swamp fire pictured here with
forearms this costume work might be the
most in-depth of them all don't you
think
from head to toe whoever put this outfit
together did not miss a single detail
SpiderMonkey if you were going to think
of the scariest animal combinations
what's the first thing that comes to
mind perhaps you think of a lion shark
or maybe even a donkey cat well don't
waste one more brain cell thinking about
it because we've got the ultimate combo
the spider monkey believe it or not
spider monkeys do exist in the wild but
the version featured in Ben 10 is even
more unbelievable even from first glance
you can tell that this four-armed alien
has a lot going on besides his bright
blue color the next thing you might
notice about spider monkey is that he
has four green eyes this attribute
combined with his extremely versatile
tail makes this furry alien extremely
agile in fact did you know that spider
monkey can actually create webs using
his tail as if that wasn't cool enough
he can also stick to and scale vertical
surfaces with a name like spider monkey
what else do you expect this alien is so
cool that one young kid decided to dress
up like him this costume is totally
wicked and it's got everything you'd
want out of a spider monkey doppelganger
not only does it have the alien
signature for arms but it also includes
multiple pairs of eyes and they're
recognizable Omnitrix symbol this kid
must be the most popular guy on the
block is there a Ben 10 alien that you'd
like to see in real life let us know in
the comments thanks for watching
[Music]